E aí
Olá você sabia que a fotografia tem o
poder de mudar drasticamente a maneira
como a gente se enxerga a gente tá aqui
para contar para vocês como a gente
descobriu isso e como a gente
transformou autoestima de milhares de
mulheres incluindo a nossa própria
autoestima Olá eu sou a Michele e eu sou
a Mariana nós somos sócios é oito anos e
o estúdio fotográfico focado em ensaios
sensuais e não somos irmãos também há 34
anos
e ameaçada de ser muito amiga nós somos
pessoas bem diferentes nós temos Gostos
diferentes estilos de vida diferentes
crenças diferentes mas tem uma coisa que
sempre mil a gente que foi o fato da
gente ser mulher e os copinhos de
cervejas não é
de vez em quando bom e se você é mulher
está nos assistindo você sabe muito bem
Como pode ser difícil e doloroso ser
mulher numa sociedade são muitos padrões
estéticos a seguir muitas regras muitos
muitas regras comportamentais né E
quando é você sua idade sexualidade tudo
fica ainda mais espinhoso para o nosso
lado quando se trata de fotografia a
gente sabe muito bem que a fotografia
principalmente fotografia sensual sempre
teve um áudio ali mais opressor Por que
historicamente foi feita de homem para
homem e para agradar os apetites
masculinos o que não leva em
consideração que nós mulheres achamos né
da própria sensualidade da sexualidade
que é muito mais amplo e abrangente do
que ali a visão masculino É claro que
com tanta regra tanta coisa a gente
nunca conseguiu se enxergar e se
encaixar em um padrão porque ensinaram
para gente que só um tipo de mulher é
que merece esse ali a sua sensualidade a
sua sexualidade quando a gente não se
encaixa nesse tipo de mulher gente fica
numa espécie de Limbo tentando alcançar
esse ideal para conseguir descer a
própria sensualidade E aí isso faz com
que a gente não consiga perceber e
enxergar a própria beleza
é mas aquela que a gente não percebeu
isso tudo que a Michele falou do nada
com a gente começou a fazer falta
sensuais a ideia a princípio era só
democratizar um pouco mais o tipo de
sensualidade os tipos de copos né e a
pesada a bandeira da autoaceitação tá é
clica Nessa proposta a gente não recebeu
o poder de transformação que a gente
tiramos
diz algumas a gente começou a conviver
diariamente com mulheres
fotografá-las conversar ouvir as suas
dores e etc a gente percebeu que a gente
tava apertando ali né em lugares muito
mais profundos na intimidade dessas
mulheres e na relação delas com elas
mesmas ele a gente pode perceber o qual
problemático e distorcido né é a relação
dessas mulheres com a própria imagem e
essa convivência nos deu a oportunidade
de também percebeste na gente e para
começar a trabalhar isso usando a
fotografia uma coisa que a gente
percebeu é que a gente é exposta a
muitas imagens né então rede social
revista televisão cinema todo mundo
trabalha para criar um ideal de mulher
que muitas vezes não corresponde à
realidade elétrico assim nunca
corresponde e a gente começa a entender
ao longo da vida quer que uma mulher
ideal é aquela se a gente não fazendo
desse padrão a gente se questiona E aí
um fator comparação começa a ser muito
negativo porque você começa achar que
quer né que precisa ser de um jeito e
você é de outro e essa comparação faz
com que a gente não seja capaz de
enxergar a própria Beleza então o fim
das contas olhando muito para fora e
pouco para dentro acabou que não guerra
de autoconhecimento na nossas vidas e
esse vazio ele interfere diretamente na
forma como a gente se relacionar com a
gente mesmo e como a gente se relaciona
com o uso e Todas aquelas exigências que
a Michele citou como como a gente deve
se comportar como a gente deve agir
adoeceu todas as nossas afinal não
querer precisar de uso acesa com
parceiro parceira ter vergonha da
própria sexualidade da própria
sensualidade não querer colocar uma
roupa por vergonha não Cintia adequada
Não tem sensação de merecimento é só um
sintoma de tudo isso desse mal que se
infiltrou nas nossas vidas então que a
gente percebeu e transformou em um
propósito era que é imprescindível que a
gente aprenda a lidar com que a
sociedade nos impõe e que a gente mude
essa relação com a nossa imagem ao longo
do tempo a gente percebeu que a
fotografia tem de fato esse poder de nos
ajudar Nesse quesito porque quando você
faz uma bela imagem de alguém né quando
você consegue fotografar alguém com um
olhar mais gentil mas carinhoso e fazer
uma representação belíssima daquela
mulher E cria uma relação com a imagem
dela diferente como a fotografia é uma
coisa muito visual ela veio de fato ele
ela se ver bonita ela se vê dela ela
consegue enxergar além do que
normalmente ela ver então se fotografar
se vê mais criar uma familiaridade com a
própria imagem se conhecer faz com que
elas se sintam muito mais confortáveis
na própria pele gente não é normal não
gostar da própria imagem
pode ser comum mas normal não é e você
gosta da sua imagem você se reconhece
nela você se reconhece quando você olha
uma foto quando você se olha no espelho
como que isso influencia na sua relação
com você mesmo com as pessoas à sua
volta então a gente quer te convidar a
refletir um pouco mais sobre isso e a
despertar desse transe desse mantra e de
insuficiência de que você não é bom o
bastante e o que a gente sugere é que
você começa a fazendo isso na sua e
usando a câmera do seu celular então
começa assim fotografando mais criando
uma relação com a câmera se fotografa de
todos os ângulos olha mais para se
reconhece os ângulos que você mais gosta
que você não que você gosta menos queria
realmente uma familiaridade com a sua
imagem como um todo e é importante
também lembrar que aquelas coisas que a
gente considera defeito muitas vezes são
só o reflexo de coisas boas que a gente
escolheu bebê por exemplo churrasco com
os amigos
Almoço em Família o bolo da vossa é como
o rugas e cicatrizes são provas de vida
provas de que você tá ali né que você tá
batalhando prova de superação isso tudo
é muito bonito porque o seu corpo conta
a sua história Então esquece os outros
esquece a comparação re significa o que
a sua própria imagem quer dizer para
você mesma o
connect e reconheça toda sua
potencialidade Vale lembrar que a
autoestima ela não há lugar ela é um
caminho e assim como todo o caminho você
precisa de um mapa Então por que não
deixar que o mapeamento do seu próprio
corpo de início a esse processo de
autoaceitação para você poder se
enxergar de uma vida mais doce e mais
saudável